Transcription: Asma Nacef
Relecteur: eric vautier
Abidjan over everything.
Abidjan au-dessus de tout.
Tout comme « Détroit vs Everybody »
ou « I Love New York »
ou le très célèbre
« Abidjan est le plus doux au monde »,
ces phrases résument
un état d’esprit, une vision.
Le soft power, ou « puissance douce »
en français,
est la capacité d’un État à influencer
le comportement d’autres acteurs
par des moyens qu’on ne peut pas mesurer.
Lorsqu’un Sénégalais, un Camerounais
ou encore un Français
utilise le terme « s’enjailler »,
cette personne a été
victime du soft power ivoirien.
Le nouchi est un élément
du soft power ivoirien.
Aujourd’hui, un élément de ce soft power
ivoirien est l’entertainment,
l’art du divertissement
ou l’industrie du divertissement.
Nous allons voir aujourd’hui comment
et par quels moyens.
On va parler de la musique : un
des outils les plus forts de soft power.
Ensuite, on va parler séries et films.
Enfin, on parlera
de ces grands événements
qui attirent et rassemblent du monde.
Imaginez si chacun d’entre nous pouvait
se téléporter et voyager dans le temps.
Nous pourrions traverser
le pont de Brooklyn
en écoutant « Empire State of Mind »
de Jay-Z et d’Alicia Keys,
manger une glace en bas de la tour Eiffel
en regardant « Amélie Poulain »,
ou encore se téléporter à l’époque
du premier festival de Woodstock.
Eh bien, sachez,
si nous n’avons pas ce pouvoir,
nous en possédons une petite partie.
Tout le monde écoute de la musique
ou a un artiste favori.
Cet artiste, à travers sa musique,
véhicule des messages sur son lifestyle,
sur là d’où il vient,
sur la vision de la vie.
Cela permet à l’auditeur de se projeter
et de s’imaginer être à sa place.
De manière douce, la musique va donc
influencer notre comportement.
En gros, je suis fan de cet artiste
et de sa musique,
et donc, par procuration, je vis sa vie.
« Je suis le sommet des sommets,
le sommet de l’Himalaya. »
Cette phrase est celle de Douk Saga,
créateur du Coupé-décalé.
Avec des amis en France,
à l’époque, je me rappelle, en soirée,
qaund on ne voulait pas que d’autres
personnes comprennent ce que l’on disait,
sur elles ou d’autres choses,
on utilisait des phrases de Douk Saga :
« flocon 1 appelle flocon 2 », « les gens
n’aiment pas les gens,
mais l’argent des gens »,
« l’ennemi de l’homme, c’est l’homme ».
Ces expressions sont entrées
dans la façon de parler,
le vocabulaire de plusieurs
milliers d’Africains.
Le Coupé-décalé, prôné par Douk Saga,
est une façon de vivre, de parler,
de s’habiller ou encore de se comporter.
Avec le Coupé-décalé de Douk Saga,
on s’imaginait faire la fête à Abidjan.
On s’imaginait vivre cette vie
d’enjaillement et de boucan,
être un boucantier.
Une autre influence de ce Coupé-décalé
est le père des Chinois :
DJ Arafat.
Avec ses lives, ses titres, ses
nombreux directs, ses nombreuses danses,
il a permis la démocratisation du nouchi
auprès d’un public non ivoirien.
Un autre exemple
du pouvoir de la musique :
« Gnonmi avec lait » de Fior de Bior.
Certaines personnes m’ont carrément appelé
pour me demander
de leur rapporter des Gnonmis.
Des personnes sont venues
à Abidjan pour goûter à ces Gnonmis.
DJ Arafat, Douk Saga, Fior de Bior,
avec leur musique,
sont une façon
de faire la fête à l’ivoirienne.
Une façon de vivre, une façon de parler
qui a influencé des milliers de personnes.
Friends, Sex and the City, Sous le soleil.
Quel est le point commun de ces séries ?
Elles sont mondialement connues
et montrent, chacune à leur manière,
la culture d’un pays et les lieux
iconiques de ce pays.
De beaux lieux, de beaux paysages
dans un film, donnent envie à l’audience
de découvrir le pays où a été tourné
le film ou la série.
Les pays ou les villes
les plus touristiques au monde
ont souvent une série ou un film
qui met en avant ce lieu.
Les films sur Paris avec la tour Eiffel,
sur Rio de Janeiro avec ses favelas ou
Hawaï et ses plages paradisiaques.
Je me rappelle quand j’étais petit,
à force de regarder
le « Fresh Prince of Bel-Air »,
je me disais que moi aussi,
je devais habiter à Bel-Air,
aller au lycée là-bas avec Will,
danser avec Carlton
ou rigoler avec Uncle Phil.
Le pouvoir qu’ont les films et les séries
sur nous est plus fort qu’on ne l’imagine.
Des séries comme « Ma Famille »
ou « Cacao »,
pour rester en Côte d’Ivoire,
montrent Abidjan sous différentes formes
ou nous donnent envie
de découvrir la Côte d’Ivoire.
Un autre film très connu ici,
et connu mondialement :
« Aya de Yopougon ».
La bande dessinée montre
le quartier de Yopougon
sous une autre image, une bonne image.
De ce fait, Yopougon devient
une référence nationale,
régionale et internationale.
Donner envie de visiter la Côte d’Ivoire
en la montrant à travers ses films,
ses séries ou encore ses courts-métrages,
c’est le rôle
de l’industrie cinématographique.
Séries, cinéma, court-métrage.
Aujourd’hui,
avec l’apogée du social media,
on le voit aussi avec des courts réels
ou courtes vidéos.
L’événementiel,
connu pour attirer du monde,
que ce soit des personnalités publiques
ou des leaders d’opinion.
Un événement réussit à prendre
la notoriété de celui qui l’a organisé,
mais aussi du lieu
où est tenu l’événement.
Qu’il soit musical, de mode, de danse,
un événement fait
la propagande douce d’un pays
et participe à son attractivité.
Qui ici ne veut pas aller dans le désert
du Nevada participer à Coachella ?
Aller à Rio pour son carnaval ?
Ou faire une semaine à Paris
et participer à la Fashion Week ?
A Abidjan,
il y a des événements qui participent
à l’attractivité de la ville
comme le FEMUA,
organisé par le groupe Magic System,
les différents festivals de cuisine
comme le Festival des grillades,
ou encore les festivals
autour du chocolat.
Récemment, Abidjan a accueilli
les demi-finales de The Voice,
émission mondialement connue.
Cette émission, accueillie à Abidjan,
a permis de mettre en lumière
la ville d’Abidjan
et, par exemple,
le Sofitel qui a accueilli la finale.
Il y a un événement,
dont je suis l’un des cofondateurs,
qui contribue ces derniers mois
à faire rayonner Abidjan :
la Sunday, un festival musical.
Lorsqu’on a créé la Sunday,
on n’imaginait pas l’impact
qu’on aurait sur la région
et sur la diaspora africaine,
mais pas que.
On m’a demandé, pour la petite histoire,
d’aller mixer en Australie
à cause de la Sunday.
Une personne qui a vu la Sunday
a su que j’étais un DJ.
Elle n’est jamais venue à Abidjan,
mais m’a appelé pour me demander
de venir mixer en Australie.
Dès les 1es sollicitations des médias,
nous nous sommes dit que
nous voulions faire de cet événement
un rendez-vous incontournable à Abidjan
et inscrire le festival
comme une référence ivoirienne.
Plus l’événement est gros et grand, plus
celui-ci est amené à attirer du monde.
Un événement réussi est une vitrine de ce
qui se fait de mieux en termes de culture
et de divertissement dans un pays.
Les grandes puissances veulent exercer
une influence sur les plus petits pays.
Cette influence douce
qu’est le soft power,
toutes ces grandes puissances
la possèdent.
C’est une force que l’on ne voit pas,
mais qui est très, très persuasive.
Tout à l’heure, je parlais
de propagande douce.
Prenez les Américains.
Dans tous leurs films,
on voit leur drapeau et on se dit :
« Leur pays est chic ! »
Les cérémonies des Oscars
ou des Golden Globes
renforcent la puissance culturelle
des États-Unis
parce que ce sont des événements
mondialement connus et regardés.
La France, avec son savoir-vivre,
sa cuisine, sa french touch
qu’on retrouve dans sa musique, ses films
ou les événements qu’ils vont organiser.
Alors, j’ai deux questions pour vous :
quel est le soft power du Vatican ?
Pas compliqué.
Et quel est le soft power
de l’île de la Barbade ?
L’Île de la Barbade,
c’est très simple, c’est Rihanna.
Dans le monde,
certains pays sont magnifiques,
mais on n’a jamais entendu parler d’eux.
Avez vous déjà entendu parler
de Saint-Martin ou du Turkménistan ?
Du Belize ?
Quel est le chanteur
le plus connu de ces pays ?
Avez-vous déjà entendu parler d’un
film tourné dans un de ces pays ?
En conclusion, la Côte d’Ivoire et Abidjan
sont en train de renforcer leur place
de capitale de l’industrie
du divertissement en Afrique francophone
grâce aux éléments que j’ai cités :
la musique, le cinéma et l’événementiel.
L’addition de tous ces éléments place
la Côte d’Ivoire
comme une référence en Afrique
et dans le monde.
Cela permet à la Côte d’Ivoire
d’attirer de plus en plus de monde
et d’avoir plus de personnes
pour venir écouter la musique, regarder
les films et profiter des événements.
Le divertissement s’impose
comme une des ressources
du soft power made in Côte d’Ivoire.
Abidjan over everything,
Abidjan, le plus doux...
Public : Au monde !
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)